well this is
right at the the beginning of the movie
we've spent quite a lot of time
outside in new york
and
the world is very hostile it's
incredibly hot it's noisy
and so the idea of this scene really is
that when she walks in it's the sort of
complete antithesis to the world that
she's just been in that feels
frightening
and then she comes into this oasis of
quiet
where she has a moment possibly the only
moment to sort of sit back and be of
wire and look at other people
it was really a sort of geographical
choreography this scene because it was
all about the space between these two
women like it wasn't interesting to me
to have a busy room full of people
and then to sort of glimpse claire
through that it felt much more
interesting to be very exposed in a very
big room that's completely empty
cavernous
and has this sort of strange oasis like
sound quality
and this is a moment where she is
observing whilst also being a little bit
nervous about being observed because
she's in a place where she shouldn't be
that was my invention to have a couple
that are very overtly sexualized and
doing too much public display of
affection and then the antithesis of
that a couple who are beyond that in
their life are not a couple necessarily
but who are sat together in a very sort
of poised and rigid sort of way not even
speaking because those are the
polarizations the irene's trap between
this kind of rigidity and
and claire awakens this sensuality so
the scene is actually entirely sensual
whether it's the sound of her voice or
the the wind chimes or the tinkling of
the cups or the rubbing of the stockings
it's it's a sensual experience you know
rebecca articulated that really
brilliantly with you know the shot when
i'm looking at her legs that you can
also hear in the sound design you can
hear the stockings which makes it a sort
of really sonic visceral experience
and that is of course the moment where
she also sees claire in this moment when
she thinks she is at peace where she's
not being observed there is a woman who
she doesn't know staring right at her
she's thinking and feeling why is this
woman looking at me is there too much
powder on my face is there something
wrong with me
going from indignant to deciding well
i'll just look back at her
what's interesting with claire is her
gaze
and how direct it is and how disarming
that can be
because actually when you think about it
people who have very direct gazes are
quite intimidating it doesn't matter how
soft their voice is or what they look
like or how small or big they are and in
this moment they're both in a
performance in a place where they are
performing and they are both they both
know something about the other one and
it's about why are you looking at me
what are you wanting
pardon me i don't mean to stare but
i think i know you
i'm afraid you're mistaken
no of course i know you rini
you look just the same when claire
finally walks over there's like a
sequence of these very sort of
confrontational shots with their faces
directly in the center of the frame and
they're completely clean don't you know
me you're totally seeing through irene's
eyes and therefore if you feel as
accustomed as
she is
i'm afraid i can't seem to place
[Laughter]
that's right
up until this point in the movie you're
sort of over
a lot over irene's shoulder or behind
her and when you do decide to center a
face with nothing else blurring the
frame it's incredibly confronting and a
little unnerving and you don't feel like
you really know where you are and from a
movie-making perspective as a viewer
like it's a little
upsetting almost and that moment i'm i
always like this moment very much
between these two very clean singles
that are very sort of almost like a 2d
just a small thing about this scene for
me it's like a uh
falling in love scene
you know a kind of twisted falling in
love scene but not in a bad way but kind
of it's kind of for me it's a microcosm
of their relationship that
when they look at one another
they can sort of
disrobe one another just by looking
and
and everything else falls away
everything else
and it's just
the sound of the other person the smell
of the other person
it's like this
this deep fascination but also mistrust
but also
can't look away
is this a person safe
but i like being looked both at them and
with them and
and for me that's the kind of that sets
the tone for the relationship between
the two so much of the tension that
exists in the movie is erotic like
whether it's you know literal or not or
obvious or not but it is a sort of there
is a there is a tension that comes with
sort of suppressed longings whether it's
longing to be something else or longing
for something sexually it doesn't really
matter for me this was really a pivotal
scene because it was a way of setting up
the movie as
a suspense thriller as a psychological
suspense thriller that that doesn't play
on you know
potential murderers or really obviously
frightening things but on how you are
looked at and how are you you are
perceived and the sort of discomfort of
that
we've just seen claire get her way into
the house the previous day and spend a
lot of time with irene and sort of
corner her into allowing her to come to
the dance the following night thought
she might have fallen asleep no
about on time for once oh good
up until this point the conversations
that have happened in their bedroom have
been dismissive and angry and and now
you see irene
trying to lightly tell her husband that
it's no big deal when we know precisely
it is a big deal
claire is coming hmm claire belly
that crazy woman claire there's also the
fact that most of the scene for irene is
taking place in front of a mirror which
was really crucial for us in terms of
trying to find ways for irene to reveal
her inner life
she surprised me
with a visit yesterday
yesterday why in the world didn't you
tell me this thing that irene is feeling
is this idea of a woman as another woman
that just by being who that woman is
they make you feel small and claire's
beauty makes her
interrogate and and weigh her own i
think
be nice huh
i highly doubt it i mean you be nice to
her i will be polite up until this point
we have been very much on her
perspective how she sees the world and
then we break it when brian lies down on
the bed and stares at the ceiling so yes
it's a metaphor for there's a rumble
coming there's a little crack in the in
the architecture of their marriage there
are problems there already
quit hovering go wait for me downstairs
but we're also thinking about how things
are being seen how brian is doing
something versus how irene is seeing
something
wait i'm sorry
i love you
why
you are nervous during the course of
this team there's also a sort of a play
on perspective
you know one of the tricks of the film
is trying to reveal that the person that
you think is reliably telling you the
story
is actually having a breakdown and isn't
seeing the world clearly
and that continues as she goes down the
stairs because in the mirror she's
seeing them standing very close together
it's immediately frightening and then
she turns the corner and she realizes
that her judgment was just off and
actually they're standing much further
apart
there's all of that confusion you may be
right
what i really love about this scene is
is the is the ways in which
you reveal
truth
through
how
a character chooses to recount
information that you as the audience
already know to their spouse
it's very revealing
of both of their relationships
and their undercurrents and also what
this person who hasn't even been
introduced to her husband yet is already
creating it was really apparent on this
film
that our
characters are created
as much by the other actors as they are
by us and i know that's like should be
you know that's without you know it
should go without saying but actually i
don't think we think about that enough
of how deeply collaborative
filmmaking really is